pilar what are we making from rebel
homemaker the cookbook oh my god
with drew and pilar today so today we're
making a vietnamese inspired
lemongrass beef skewers yup really
really lovely so
in this bowl that's us making it that's
right there we are
in this bowl we have um a pound of
ground beef
one pound grumpy one pound ground beef
and what we're gonna do is
put in all the seasoning so you have
over there
a tablespoon of shallots we have
one scallion that we've finely sliced
two tablespoons of chopped lemongrass
and then we also have this is a slightly
special ingredient it's a lime leaf
but if you can't get lime leaf you can
do
two uh two limes zested so you can
totally substitute that that slime
and then one tablespoon of fish sauce i
love fish sauce i love fish sauce it has
that really
nice like saltiness nothing absolutely
nothing
and then we have one half tablespoon of
curry curry powder and the last thing
here we have two tablespoons of cilantro
stems
so the reason why i love using it is
sometimes i find
with uh cilantro leaves they tend to
discolor and wilt when you're using them
in something like this especially in any
heat
exactly so i like to use a mini ice
cream scoop for this or cooking oh i
know you do
the ice cream for everything by the way
i think every single recipe we've used
peanut butter cookies ice cream scoop
yeah exactly
but you can also use tablespoons if you
want so you're going to basically do
one scoop of the meat mixture
and you're gonna form it into slightly
like cylindrical
pattern and then you're gonna nestle
that
stick into the meat mixture
all right so now we have a pan i'm gonna
de-glove real quick
we're gonna just do a tablespoon so not
all of it a tablespoon
of coconut oil and we're gonna swirl
that
what's nice is i find coconut oil
in certain cuisines to be the anomaly
that's like the house guest you didn't
want to come to the dinner party but
with this recipe i think it's
it works right yeah it works really
nicely and we're basically going to cook
off the skewers
and they only take eight minutes total
they're gonna get a really nice
uh golden crust oh that smells amazing
that already smells amazing i love this
dish
so much because of how easy it is
to make it and how special the flavor
profile is and this is so doable for
any home cook out there and
when it gets too complex i don't think
i'm very good at
introducing things that intimidate me i
feel like
i have to be able to do it yeah and
these are just so simple
and yet really complex in flavor yeah
and
the recipes in this book are empowering
and that is important yeah so my
favorite way to eat these skewers
is to make a little bit of a wrap so you
put
the meat in you can take out the
lemongrass right here
and then you can put whatever herbs you
like so
we have some cilantro we have some mint
too and some basil
um okay and then you just sausage myself
yeah
sauce it has limes it has chilies it has
honey
it has um fish sauce as well roll it up
ready bun up
i think it deserves a little low a
little shimmy
i'm going to do a full three chick shoot
i love it it's just a really really
delicious
dish this is the kind of dish i'm going
to go back
to the simplicity of how easy it is to
make
this is a dish that is what you get at a
restaurant
and you're just like i could not make
that at home
and yet you can
um well pilar uh after this announcement
um i'm very excited to continue talking
about this endeavor and all the things
we get to do together as culinary
partners in crime
um so be sure to pick up a copy of our
cookbook
rebel homemaker um i'm so proud of this
book and i'm so excited it's coming out
so
november 2nd rebel homemaker
you